This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every time you go to the bathroom, you should thank Alexander Cummings. We actually featured a whole story about him because Alexander Cummings was the first person to patent a flushable toilet. He didn't invent the flush toilet, but he did connect it to an S-shaped pipe, which uses water to stop sewerrogas from coming up and stinking up your home. And before Alexander coming, that used to happen a lot.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。每次你去洗手间时，都应该感谢亚历山大·卡明斯。我们实际上专门做过一篇关于他的报道，因为亚历山大·卡明斯是第一个为可冲水马桶申请专利的人。他并没有发明抽水马桶，但他将其连接到了一根S形管道上，这根管道利用水来阻止下水道气体回流并污染你的家。而在亚历山大·卡明斯之前，这种情况经常发生。
Whatever was underneath the toilet could come back up. People didn't like bad smells, but they also thought that bad smells carried disease. That's how the flush came about. That's Chelsea Wald. I'm the author of Piped Dreams, the urgent global quest to transform the toilet. The flush toilet took a while to catch on, but once it did, it became part of a system we still use today, which Chelsea calls the gold standard. Here's how it works. Your poop once deposited into the toilet and you flesh it down goes into a sewer system that runs under the city.
马桶下方的任何东西都可能反涌上来。人们讨厌恶臭，但他们也认为恶臭会传播疾病。这就是冲水马桶诞生的原因。那是切尔西·沃尔德。我是《管道之梦：改造厕所的全球紧迫使命》一书的作者。抽水马桶花了很长时间才流行起来，但一旦普及，它就成为了我们今天仍在使用的系统的一部分，切尔西称之为黄金标准。它是这样运作的。你的便便一旦排入马桶，当你按下冲水阀，它就会进入城市地下的下水道系统。
And there it combines with water and with everyone else's poop and anything anyone puts into their sinks and their toilets and their showers and their washing machines and their dishwasher flows through to a treatment plant and in the treatment plant, bacteria help to clean up the sewage. The treatment plant produces cleaned up waste water, which is usually returned to our water supply and it filters out all the solids. The flush toilet, the sewer system,
在那里，它与水、与其他所有人的便便，以及任何人倒入水槽、马桶、淋浴间、洗衣机和洗碗机的东西汇合，流向处理厂。在处理厂里，细菌帮助净化污水。处理厂产生净化后的废水，通常会返回到我们的供水系统中，并且它会过滤掉所有的固体。抽水马桶、下水道系统
and the treatment plant make up the gold standard. In a lot of ways, it's a really good system. Toilet technology, the toilet systems that people's developed in the 19th and early 20th century that we still use today fundamentally work very well at keeping our cities clean and keeping us healthy. But look, Chelsea Wall didn't write a whole book about how toilets are great. keeping our cities clean and keeping us healthy. Look, Chelsea Wall didn't write a whole book about how toilets are great.
以及处理厂构成了黄金标准。在很多方面，这确实是一个很好的系统。厕所技术，即人们在19世纪和20世纪初开发并沿用至今的厕所系统，在保持城市清洁和维护我们的健康方面从根本上运作得非常好。但听着，切尔西·沃尔德可不是写了一整本书来讲述马桶有多么伟大。保持我们的城市清洁并让我们保持健康。听着，切尔西·沃尔德可不是写了一整本书来讲述马桶有多么伟大。
The gold standard has some big limitations. I like to think of it as a paradox. I am very happy for the toilet that I have and that I've been able to use my whole life. But the paradox is that the systems are wasteful and they are not suited to the challenges of the 21st century. Today, the problem with toilets, which else you want.
黄金标准有一些很大的局限性。我喜欢把它看作是一个悖论。我对我拥有的马桶以及我一生都能使用它感到非常高兴。但这个悖论是，这些系统非常浪费，它们不适应21世纪的挑战。今天，正如切尔西·沃尔德所说，马桶存在的问题是
So the flush toilet is pretty effective, but what are the problems with it? I think everybody would know by now that toilets waste water. They use fresh, drinkable water most of the time to flush our poop, which just seems silly. The reason that they do this uses waters for two purposes. One is to wash out the bowl and carry away the poop and then the other reason is to seal the toilet to prevent sewer gases from coming back up. Old toilets use something from 3.5 to seven gallons to flush, so it's like a waterfall of freshwater used to flesh down pee, which is crazy, because that's just liquid or your poop. And some households, you know,
所以抽水马桶相当有效，但它有什么问题呢？我想大家现在都知道马桶浪费水。它们大多数时候用新鲜的可饮用水来冲走我们的便便，这看起来太荒谬了。它们这样做的原因是为了两个目的使用水。一个是冲洗便池并带走便便，另一个原因是密封马桶以防止下水道气体回流。老式马桶冲一次水要用3.5到7加仑，这就像用瀑布般的淡水来冲洗尿液，这太疯狂了，因为那只是液体或你的便便。在某些家庭中，你知道的
that can be a quarter of their household water consumption is just toilet flushing. New innovations and in recent decades have brought that down. The current federal standard is 1.6 gallons. And low flow toilets are lower than that. But one thing that people may not think about is that more and more people are getting toilets every year as they hook up to piped water and not just in the US, less in the US, but around the world. This is a growing issue. Worldwide, one estimate is that people use 40 billion gallons of fresh water to flush toilets,
这可能占他们家庭用水量的四分之一，仅仅是冲马桶。近几十年的新创新将这一数字降了下来。目前的联邦标准是1.6加仑。低流量马桶则更少。但人们可能没有想到的一件事是，随着越来越多的人接通管道供水，每年有越来越多的人使用马桶，这不仅在美国，虽然在美国较少，但在世界各地都是如此。这是一个日益严重的问题。据全球估计，人们每天用400亿加仑的淡水来冲马桶，
which is six times the daily water consumption of Africa. That's one portion of the worldwide wastewater usage, which is 100 trillion gallons of wastewater, which is a number that's only going up. That number might increase by 50 percent by 2050. We don't have that water to spare. So by that time, half the world's population is going to be living in water stress regions, which means that at least part of the year they won't have enough water.
这相当于非洲每日用水量的六倍。这是全球废水使用量的一部分，全球废水使用量高达100万亿加仑，而且这个数字还在不断上升。到2050年，这个数字可能会增加50%。我们没有那么多富余的水。因此，到那时，世界上一半的人口将生活在缺水地区，这意味着至少在一年中的部分时间里，他们将没有足够的水。
People want to hook up to flush toilets that use water. They are a symbol of economic development. They're a symbol of progress and success. And because we don't have an alternative really that also represents that people, they're going to continue to hook up to flush toilets when they can. In the book, you point out some new kinds of toilets that reduce our water usage. Can you tell me about those? If we don't want to use water and our toilets, or we want to use much less water in our toilets, we have dry toilets. Those are toilets that don't use
人们想要连接使用水的抽水马桶。它们是经济发展的象征。它们是进步和成功的象征。由于我们确实没有其他同样能代表这一点的替代品，人们在条件允许时仍会继续安装抽水马桶。在书中，你指出了几种能减少我们用水量的新型马桶。你能跟我讲讲那些吗？如果我们不想在马桶里用水，或者想在马桶里少用很多水，我们有干马桶。那些是不使用的马桶
any water and you might use a cover material over it. And you can kind of think like an outhouse can be a dry toilet or a bucket in some cases. People have adopted those. They're not terribly popular. They're so see, isn't you know, they's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see,
任何水，你可以在上面用一层覆盖材料。你可以这样想，比如简易茅厕可以是一个干马桶，或者在某些情况下是一个桶。人们已经接受了这些。它们并不是非常受欢迎。它们是如此可见，你知道的，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，
there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, there's so see, new coatings for toilets under development that kind of let the poop slide out of them more so that you don't need as much water to scour the toilet and get all the poop out of it. They're kind of more self-cleaning.
它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，它们是如此可见，正在开发中的新型马桶涂层可以让便便更容易滑落，这样你就不需要那么多水来冲洗马桶并把所有的便便清理干净了。它们在某种程度上更具自洁能力。
There's also a toilet under development that uses like a spatula to scoop around the toilet bowl and then it doesn't require water as well. So there's a lot of creative ideas under development. All of these ideas, I mean, they seem futuristic, but on the other hand, there's something so logical about them. It's almost as if if you just took the time to think about it, you might think it up yourself, you know, how are you going to get this poop out of the bowl? Okay, I'll get a spatula. So I think it is, there's a lot of clever engineering in it, but there's also just a question of thinking outside the toilet bowl or thinking outside the, with respect to how to deal with this problem.
还有一款正在开发中的马桶，它用类似刮刀的东西在马桶内部刮擦，这样它也不需要水。因此，有很多正在开发中的创意。所有这些想法，我的意思是，它们看起来很有未来感，但另一方面，它们又有着非常合乎逻辑的一面。就好像如果你花时间去思考，你自己也能想出来，你知道的，你打算怎么把这个便便从马桶里弄出去？好吧，我拿一把刮刀。所以我觉得，里面有很多聪明的工程设计，但这也只是一个跳出马桶思考，或者在如何处理这个问题上跳出常规思考的问题。
The flush toilet is not the most efficient way to deal with our waste, but you could replace it with another kind of toilet. But then there's the sewer system. Like most cities built their sewer infrastructure a long time ago before they had a big increase in population. And it's so much bigger problem to deal with in the toilet because the sewer system is too expensive to replace. Can you talk about why our sewers are getting overwhelmed? When you add rainwater in there, the sewers have to handle just like a much bigger flow of water, and that can overwhelm the sewers, and it can also overwhelm the treatment plants at the end of the shores.
抽水马桶并不是处理我们废物的最高效方式，但你可以用另一种马桶来代替它。然而接着还有下水道系统。就像大多数城市在人口大幅增长很久以前就建造了下水道基础设施一样。处理下水道比处理马桶要麻烦得多，因为下水道系统更换的成本太高了。你能谈谈为什么我们的下水道不堪重负吗？当你把雨水加进去时，下水道必须承受大得多的水流，这会使下水道不堪重负，也可能会使末端的污水处理厂不堪重负。
And that's why a lot of these systems are designed to release raw sewage into waterways during these events. And because of climate change, these events are becoming more and more frequent and bigger. And so cities are dealing with more and more of these wet weather events where they are Unfortunately releasing raw sewage into their local waters. It's not something they want to do But it's how the systems are designed and fixing that is really expensive You wrote about South Bend and Indiana where they were having overflows a lot pretty much every time There was like a tenth of an inch of rain and this is where I was really surprised when Pete Buttigieg showed up in your book. Oh
这就是为什么许多这类系统被设计成在发生这些情况时将未经处理的污水排放到水道中。由于气候变化，这些事件正变得越来越频繁、规模越来越大。因此，城市正在应对越来越多的这种湿天气事件，他们不幸地将未经处理的污水排放到当地水域中。这不是他们想做的事，但这就是系统的设计方式，而修复这一点成本极高。你写到了印第安纳州的南本德，那里经常发生溢流，几乎每次降雨达到十分之一英寸时都会发生。这就是皮特·布蒂吉格出现在你的书中时让我真正感到惊讶的地方。哦
Yeah, I was writing that section when he was running for president and the whole time I was thinking Gosh when this book comes out. I have no idea You know what this section is going to mean to people And here he is now the Secretary of Transportation I have no idea what this section is going to mean to people. And here he is now, the Secretary of Transportation. So I guess it worked out okay. So one of the problems that Pete Buttigieg was trying to solve was this idea of stormwater overwhelming the sewage system
是的，他竞选总统时我正在写那一节，整个过程中我都在想，天哪，当这本书出版时。我不知道，你知道的，这一节对人们意味着什么。而现在他成了交通部长。我不知道这一节对人们意味着什么。而现在他成了交通部长。所以我想结果还算不错。因此，皮特·布蒂吉格试图解决的问题之一就是暴雨淹没污水系统这一问题
flowing out into the St. Joseph River. So what was the solution there? So they have been at the forefront of developing smart sewers, so putting sensors in sewers. The sewers are definitely an old tech, but they are very hard to put sensors in. So, you know, as everything in cities has gotten kind of wired up, sewers have been a little bit slower because it's very corrosive environment in there. But scientists at Notre Dame and some other universities worked out how to put sensors into the sewers there and get a better handle on what was happening in the sewers that they had.
流入圣约瑟夫河。那么那里的解决方案是什么呢？所以他们一直处于开发智能下水道的前沿，也就是在下水道中安装传感器。下水道绝对是一项旧技术，但在其中安装传感器非常困难。所以，你知道的，随着城市里的万物都联网了，下水道的进展要慢一些，因为那里的环境腐蚀性很强。但圣母大学和其他一些大学的科学家们研究出了如何在当地的下水道中安装传感器，并更好地掌握现有下水道中发生的情况。
And what it turned out was that there was extra capacity in the sewers that they didn't know about and they weren't really using during these events. And they were able to put devices in that would then better use that capacity automatically during these wet weather events. And just in that way, by better using the sewers that they had, reducing the number of overflows. It's not a perfect solution because they still do have overflows, but it just used the capacity of the shores a lot better. And this kind of sewer sensor technology is now really growing.
结果表明，下水道中其实存在他们并不知道的额外容量，而在这些事件发生时，他们并没有真正利用这些容量。他们能够安装设备，以便在这些湿天气事件中自动更好地利用这些容量。通过这种方式，通过更好地利用现有的下水道，减少了溢流的次数。这不是一个完美的解决方案，因为他们仍然会有溢流，但它确实大大更好地利用了下水道的容量。这种下水道传感器技术现在正在真正增长。
I mean, there's a lot of cities interested in it and installing it to eliminate these sewer overflows. So, South Bend shows us how we can take better advantage of the sewer infrastructure that we have in place in our cities. It's not just a question of better using the capacity of those sewers or investing in them in a way that makes them work better in the way that they're intended, but we can also use them in new ways. One issue is overflows, and the other problems with sewers are fat birds.
我的意思是，有很多城市对此感兴趣并进行安装，以消除这些下水道溢流。因此，南本德向我们展示了如何更好地利用我们城市中现有的下水道基础设施。这不仅是更好地利用这些下水道容量或以使其按预期更好地工作的方式进行投资的问题，我们还可以以新的方式使用它们。一个问题是溢流，下水道的另一个问题是“胖山”（脂肪山）。
I mean, these get covered a lot in the news, but could you describe a fat bird for people who don't know about them? Oh, yeah. So fat bird is the other problem of mixing everything into the sewer. By now, I hope you've heard the flushing wet wipes is bad. A lot of people haven't heard that yet, but there's these growing trend toward having these adult-wet wipes, adult version of baby wipes, I guess, instead of toilet paper and people are fleshing them like toilet paper. Those go down into the system along with any trash in there and
我的意思是，新闻中对此有很多报道，但你能为那些不知道的人描述一下什么是“胖山”吗？哦，是的。所以“胖山”是将所有东西混合到下水道中的另一个问题。到目前为止，我希望你已经听说过冲湿纸巾是不好的。很多人还没听说过这个，但现在有一种日益增长的趋势，人们开始使用这种成人湿纸巾，也就是婴儿湿纸巾的成人版，我想，用来代替卫生纸，人们像卫生纸一样把它们冲下去。这些东西连同里面的任何垃圾一起进入系统，
they mix with the grease that people, restaurants as well, pour into the sewers. And this does some crazy chemistry down there. And forms, you know, accretes into a horrible blob and it can get really hard like a rock even or it can take all kinds of different forms and textures and it just grows and grows, you know, diapers in there and needles and everything until it can clog a sewer. And that's what, you know, has been called a fat bird. Hundreds clog up London's 150 year old sewer network. None bigger than the white chapel fat bird in East London, 130 tonne, monster. Crews worked for nine weeks above ground and down below,
它们与人们以及餐馆倒入下水道的油脂混合在一起。这在下面产生了一些疯狂的化学反应。并形成，你知道的，堆积成一个可怕的团块，它甚至可以变得像石头一样硬，或者它可以呈现出各种不同的形式和质地，它只是不断地生长，你知道的，里面的尿布、针头和各种东西，直到它堵塞下水道。这就是，你知道的，被称为“胖山”的东西。数百个堵塞了伦敦拥有150年历史的下水道网络。没有比东伦敦的白教堂“胖山”更大的了，这是一个130吨的庞然大物。工人们在地面上下连续工作了九周，
breaking it up then sucking it up and trucking it away. It's really, it's just costing cities huge amounts of money, this problem. And it's also really a horrible thing for sewer workers to have to go down and clean up. And I think people don't think about that part of it. You know, that someone actually has to go down and clean up your mess, go into the sewer gases, use pickaxe at times or pressure, hose, and and get those things out of there. So that's why cities are sort of desperately telling residents to stop fleshing the wet
将其粉碎，然后吸走并用卡车运走。这确实给城市造成了巨额资金损失，这个问题。对于下水道工人来说，这也是一件非常可怕的事情，他们不得不下去清理。我想人们并没有考虑到这一部分。你知道的，居然真的有人得下去清理你的烂摊子，走入下水道气体中，有时还得用镐或高压水枪，把那些东西从里面弄出来。这就是为什么城市在绝望地告诉居民不要再把湿纸巾冲下去了
wipes and to stop pouring grease down their sinks. I don't know how far the message is getting because they say it's gotten quite bad during the pandemic, especially. Yeah. So the last part of the process is the treatment plant. What are the limitations of our water treatment process? All water discharges basically go into the sewers. I mean, there's some regulation on industry about what can go in there.
纸巾，不要再把油脂倒入水槽。我不知道这个信息传达得怎么样，因为他们说在疫情期间情况变得相当糟糕，尤其是这样。是的。所以这个过程的最后一部分是处理厂。我们的水处理过程有哪些局限性？所有的排水基本上都进入了下水道。我的意思是，工业界对什么可以进入其中有一些规定。
But pretty much anything can make its way into the sewers and flow to the wastewater treatment plant. That makes it very difficult, but the basic technology that's used to treat the sewage, which was designed more than 100 years ago, just isn't designed to eliminate a lot of these different kinds of pollution, toxic chemicals and plastic pollution in the sewage that have been developed in the last 100 years. And so wastewater treatment plants have the choice of adding on more and more treatment steps to filter out and eliminate these pollutants, which can be very expensive, and a lot of municipalities can't afford it. Or they end up discharging it into waterways.
但几乎任何东西都可以进入下水道并流向污水处理厂。这使得事情变得非常困难，但用于处理污水的核心技术是100多年前设计的，根本无法消除过去100年中产生的许多不同种类的污染、有毒化学物质和污水中的塑料污染。因此，污水处理厂面临的选择是增加越来越多的处理步骤来过滤和消除这些污染物，这可能非常昂贵，许多城市负担不起。或者它们最终将其排放到水道中。
It is monitored by the EPA in the US, but not for all of these substances, just for a limited number of heavy metals in other substances. So that creates a problem. The central tension of all this is like we have a toilet that mercifully removes us from our waste problem in our house and connects it to a sewer and it removes it. So, efficiently, we think it just goes away. It just all disappears completely. It's still there. It's just collecting it in a fat perk or being released into a river or something to that effect. I also just thought that it all just went away.
在美国，它受到环保署（EPA）的监控，但不是对所有这些物质进行监控，只对有限数量的重金属和其他物质进行监控。这就产生了一个问题。这一切的核心矛盾在于，我们有一个马桶，它仁慈地将我们从家里的废物问题中解脱出来，并将其连接到下水道，然后将其排走。如此高效，以至于我们认为它就这么消失了。它完全消失得无影无踪。它其实还在那里。只是被收集在“胖山”里，或者被排放到河流中诸如此类的地方。我以前也以为它就这么完全消失了。
I did imagine that, I mean, to the extent that I thought about it, which I'm sure I wasn't really thinking, but I thought, you know, poop is biodegradable. It just, yeah, just disappears. In the book, you talk about the problems with our conventional toilet system, and you also visit some places trying different approaches. Like, this one you describe is a subdivision experiment in snake, which is a city in the Netherlands.
我是这么想象的，我的意思是，就我思考的程度而言，我确信我当时并没有真正思考，但我曾想，你知道的，便便是可生物降解的。它会，是的，它只是消失了。在书中，你谈到了我们传统马桶系统的问题，你还走访了一些尝试不同方法的地点。比如，你描述的这个是荷兰一个名叫斯奈克的城市的住宅区实验。
They have this new toilet technology that's kind of mind-blowing. How does that system work, and could you describe it for us? I live in the Netherlands, so it wasn't a bar trip for me, but it was a few hours north. It's in housing complex of 200 units. And each of these units has a vacuum toilet. So you might know vacuum toilets from airplanes or maybe boats, and you would not want one
他们拥有这种让人大开眼界的全新马桶技术。那个系统是如何运作的，你能为我们描述一下吗？我住在荷兰，所以对我来说这不是一次长途旅行，但也往北开了一几个小时。它位于一个有200个单元的住宅区里。这些单元中的每一个都有一个真空马桶。所以你可能从飞机或船上了解过真空马桶，而你绝对不会想要一个
of those in your home. They're really horrible and they're loud. But actually, people have developed really nice, easy to use vacuum toilets. So I used one in the headquarters of the company that has developed this project alongside a university and, you know, funding partner. Those toilets are, they look mostly like a toilet, they have these kind of glowing blue buttons and you press them in a little. There's a tiny bit of water in there, which I don't even think the water has to be in there.
那样的东西在你的家里。它们真的很糟糕而且很吵。但实际上，人们已经开发出了非常美观、易于使用的真空马桶。所以我曾在开发这个项目的公司总部使用过一个，该公司与一所大学以及（你知道的）资助伙伴合作。这些马桶，它们看起来大体上就像一个马桶，它们有这种发光的蓝色按钮，你按一下它们就会稍微……里面有一点水，我觉得里面甚至都不需要有水。
It's just, it's described as a kind of security blanket. It just makes people feel comfortable. And, you know, it's closed, it opens and it just goes, whoosh! And whatever you've put in there comes out the bottom and it's very concentrated. And from there it flows to a treatment facility that's on the premises of this housing development. It's a little house just in the center. You would not know what it was. You would think it was like the headquarters of this housing development or the erect center or something. And in there is an anaerobic digester in which
它只是被描述为一种“安全毯”。它只是让人们感到舒适。而且，你知道的，它是封闭的，打开然后就会“呼”的一声！你放进去的东西都会从底部出来，而且非常浓缩。从那里它流向这个住宅区园区内的一个处理设施。它是一个位于中心的小房子。你根本认不出它是什么。你会以为它是这个住宅区的总部或者娱乐中心什么的。里面有一个厌氧消化池，其中
microbes turn this toilet waste into biogas for the housing complex. So they use it to heat the housing complex. So it's just like your poop is powering your home or heating your home. And they also add to that food from their sink. So they have food grinders in their sinks, and they send that in there too, and that can be digested as well by the microbes. Conventional wastewater treatment plants use aerobic digestion, and aerobic bacteria require a lot of oxygen and so that requires a lot of energy to pump the oxygen through the sewage but an anaerobic digester does not require oxygen pump and so it
微生物将这些马桶废物转化为住宅区的沼气。所以他们用它来为住宅区供暖。所以这就像是你的便便在为你的家提供动力或供暖。他们还在其中加入了来自水槽的食物。他们在水槽里安装了食物粉碎机，也将这些食物送进去，微生物也可以将其消化。传统的污水处理厂使用好氧消化，而好氧细菌需要大量的氧气，因此这需要大量的能量把氧气泵入污水中，但厌氧消化池不需要泵入氧气，所以它
uses much less energy in addition to creating energy. Yeah, I mean it's really remarkable and when you hear about it you think, well this is the greatest thing in the world. Why does everybody do this? And people from all over the world tour this facility. And with the mindset that maybe they'll change their, you know, their sewage and toilet systems. And then what happens? I asked that question. People I was talking to who work on this system just told me in a very disappointed way that you know it's been very difficult. Everyone just goes home and we think what they do is they install conventional infrastructure. They just don't really trust that the system is going to work. They don't want to take the risk to find out. If people will like the vacuum toilets.
除了产生能量之外，消耗的能量也少得多。是的，我的意思是这真的很了不起，当你听到这个时你会想，这真是世界上最棒的事情。为什么不是每个人都这么做呢？来自世界各地的人们都来参观这个设施。带着也许他们会改变他们的（你知道的）污水和马桶系统的想法。然后发生了什么？我问了这个问题。跟我交谈的、致力于这个系统的人非常失望地告诉我，你知道的，这非常困难。每个人都回家了，我们觉得他们的做法是安装传统的 infrastruktuur（基础设施）。他们只是真的不相信这个系统会起作用。他们不想冒这个险去弄清楚。人们是否会喜欢真空马桶。
If the plumbers will be able to fix them, if they can get all the regulatory stuff in line, you know, there's just a lot of barriers. When you have a system that's so widespread and so standard as the conventional system, adopting something so novel. I mean, it's disappointing that people don't want to try better toilet system, but also, you know, using poop for energy sounds really radical and maybe gross to a lot of people. Do you think that our own taboos and discomfort with our, you know, excreta makes it so that design innovation is more difficult? It's funny because after spending years working on this topic and writing a book, it's a
水管工是否能够修理它们，他们是否能把所有监管方面的事情都理顺，你知道的，有很多障碍。当一个系统如此广泛、如此成为传统系统的标准时，采用如此新颖的东西。我的意思是，人们不想尝试更好的马桶系统令人失望，但同时，你知道的，用便便来发电听起来非常激进，对许多人来说可能有点恶心。你认为我们自己的禁忌以及对我们（你知道的）排泄物的反感，是否使得设计创新变得更加困难？有趣的是，在花了几 年时间研究这个话题并写了一本书之后，这有些
little hard for me to connect to my own sense of disgust around the topic. So it takes talking to other people for me to recall what it feels like to talk about, to be uncomfortable about talking about poop and spreading it on my garden or whatever. Of course, I think poop smells bad, but I don't have that same kind of disgust around it. But yes, I mean research shows that disgust is a very strong motion. It is a problem that, you know, as I was doing this research came up again and again, could people overcome the Yuck Factor? And could the Yuck Factor rear its head at a very inconvenient time? So say you're halfway through a project or you have, you know, a fertilizer project going and you've invested all of this time and effort into it. And then suddenly
让我很难将自己与对这个话题的厌恶感联系起来。因此，我需要与其他人交谈，才能回想起谈论、对谈论便便感到不舒服、或者把它撒在我的花园里等等是什么感觉。当然，我觉得便便闻起来很臭，但我对它并没有那种强烈的厌恶感。但是的，我的意思是研究表明，厌恶是一种非常强烈的情绪。这是一个问题，你知道的，当我进行这项研究时，这个问题一次又一次地出现：人们能否克服“恶心因素”？“恶心因素”是否会在非常不合时宜的时候抬头？比方说你进行项目进行到一半，或者你有一个（你知道的）肥料项目正在进行，并且你已经投入了所有的时间和精力。然后突然之间
the public gets a hold of it and they're disgusted and you get shut down. Something like that could happen. So there's a real fear of that. I think it's changing as people start to care more and more about the problems that innovators are trying to solve, I think that can counterbalance the disgust, but there are still hundreds of millions of people who don't even have that. What is it like in areas of the world without a modern flush toilet system? There's usually something there, but it's informal or it's not organized. So you might have pit latrines.
公众知道了这件事，他们感到恶心，然后你被迫关停。类似的事情可能会发生。所以这确实让人感到害怕。我认为随着人们开始越来越关心创新者试图解决的问题，这种情况正在改变，我认为这可以抵消厌恶感，但仍有数亿人甚至连这一点都做不到。世界上没有现代抽水马桶系统的地区是什么样的？那里通常有一些设施，但它们是非正式的，或者没有组织。所以你可能会有旱厕。
And the problem is that when those pit latrines fill up, people have to call somebody to empty them. There's often not a professional service or the professional service that does exist is too expensive. And so they call an informal worker, someone who's highly stigmatized, who calms and digs it out and then leaves the contents from the pitiletry somewhere other than a treatment plant for sure, maybe even just digging a hole next to the house and putting it there
问题是当这些旱厕填满时，人们必须找人来清掏。通常没有专业服务，或者现有的专业服务太贵了。所以他们会找一个非正式的工人，一个饱受污名化的人，他会来把东西挖出来，然后把旱厕里的东西倒在肯定不是处理厂的地方，甚至可能只是在房子旁边挖个洞把东西倒在那里
or dumping them in a waterway. So you have a really disorganized system. These are places where it's not easy to imagine building the kinds of sewer systems that we see in American cities, nor as I've described, I mean our sewer systems necessarily big sewer systems, necessarily the best option. People are working now as an kind of incremental improvement on making these pit latrines into a more organized system, so creating services that can safely empty them and then take them to treatment plants.
或者把它们倾倒在水道里。所以你拥有一个非常无序的系统。在这些地方，很难想象建造我们在美国城市中看到的那些下水道系统，正如我所描述的，我的意思是我们的下水道系统，未必庞大的下水道系统就是最佳选择。人们现在正在努力作为渐进式改进的一部分，将这些旱厕变成一个更有组织的系统，比如建立能够安全清掏并将其运送到处理厂的服务。
That's a step that would go really far in the right direction. And it requires a little bit of innovation, but really a lot of organization and political will, mainly, to serve these informal areas that have very little infrastructure. But another piece where people don't have sewers currently, there's a lot of opportunity there to do something new in places that have not yet been able to afford these kinds of comprehensive sewer systems.
这是一个朝着正确方向迈出一大步的举措。这需要一点创新，但实际上需要大量的组织工作和政治意愿，主要是为了服务于那些基础设施极少、非正式的地区。但另一个人们目前没有下水道的地方，在那些尚无力承担此类综合下水道系统的地区，有很多机会做一些新事情。
It is interesting that it's kind of just like a transport problem. It's just like we have one transport system, which is a great deal of water moving things to a system. Or you have people taking buckets of things out and moving them to other places essentially. It really is like a systems and transport issue when you get down to it, right? Yeah, I guess so. Yeah, yeah, how can you get this stuff someplace safe? There is the idea of these hyper-local decentralized systems where centralized systems, where everything can be kind of treated on the spot. The Gates Foundation had the reinvent the toilet challenge, which encouraged research teams to come up with ideas for these kinds of toilets that could neutralize the waste and create
有趣的是，这在某种程度上就像是一个运输问题。就像我们有一个运输系统，用大量的水把东西输送到一个系统中。或者你有人拿着装东西的桶出去，把它们运到其他地方。归根结底，这确实像是一个系统和运输问题，对吧？是的，我想是这样。是的，是的，你如何把这些东西送到安全的地方？有一种想法是这种超本地化的分散系统，在那里集中式系统中的一切都可以在现场得到某种程度的处理。盖茨基金会曾举办过“重新发明厕所”挑战赛，鼓励研究团队为这类厕所提出创意，以便在中和废物的同进，还能
resources on the spot in places where there is no infrastructure. I mean, so far, those are still in development, let's say. It's a big dream, it's a big dream, but a worthy one. I think that the idea that the Gates Foundation had, Bill Gates had, that people could kind of leapfrog the conventional system and get to something better. Don't go down that path. Find a new one, make a new one. I think that, you know, communities need to decide for themselves, you know, how they
在没有基础设施的地方就地创造资源。我的意思是，到目前为止，这些仍然处于开发阶段，可以说。这是一个伟大的梦想，一个伟大的梦想，但也是一个值得追求的梦想。我认为盖茨基金会、比尔·盖茨的想法是，人们可以某种程度上实现跨越传统系统并达到更好水平的飞跃。不要走那条老路。寻找一条新路，创造一条新路。我认为，你知道的，社区需要自己决定，你知道的，他们
want to organize their own waste. And in part, or they need to be consulted in that as well. But it is a problem that's still unsolved. I mean, obviously, if it were solved, we wouldn't be talking about it. But I think we're seeing increasing attention to it and a lot of different kinds of solutions appearing, enough that there's reason to be hopeful. I want to talk about another equity issue around toilets, which is access to public toilets. The number of public toilets around the world has gone way down, especially in the United States. Why is that? So, public toilets are a big cost to a city.
想要如何组织他们的废物。在某种程度上，或者他们也需要在这方面被征求意见。但这仍然是一个尚未解决的问题。我的意思是，很明显，如果它已经解决了，我们就不会在这里谈论它了。但我认为我们看到了越来越多的关注，并且出现了许多不同类型的解决方案，足以让我们有理由抱有希望。我想谈谈围绕厕所的另一个公平问题，那就是公共厕所的获得。世界各地的公共厕所数量大幅下降，尤其是在美国。为什么会这样？所以，公共厕所对一个城市来说是一项巨大的开支。
My understanding is there used to be quite a lot of public toilets in the US, but they were paid toilets. Problem was the women paid, but the men didn't have to. And so in the 1970s, people started pointing that out as being sexist, which it was, and demanded free toilets for everybody, which they got, except for the fact that that meant that cities didn't really want to keep up those free toilets. Yeah, they just turned into big burdens for cities and cities started taking them out.
据我所了解，美国过去曾有相当多的公共厕所，但它们是收费厕所。问题是女性要付费，而男性不需要。所以在20世纪70年代，人们开始指出这是性别歧视，事实也确实如此，并要求为每个人提供免费厕所，他们也确实得到了免费厕所，除了这意味着城市其实并不想维护这些免费厕所。是的，它们对城市来说变成了沉重的负担，城市开始把它们拆除。
And the public toilets that did exist were kind of gross and nobody wanted to really use them as a result. Our cities are really depleted of public toilets. And it's a really big problem. Really for everybody who wants to go out into public life, although people who, you know, the privilege of doing so can often walk into a cafe and use it, but there really are a lot of people who don't have that privilege who won't be invited into a cafe and allowed to use the toilet there. Yeah, we were relying on a private system, like of public toilets, are basically in private cafes and
而那些确实存在的公共厕所也有点恶心，因此没有人真正想去使用它们。我们的城市真的缺乏公共厕所。这是一个非常大的问题。对每一个想走进公共生活的人来说都是如此，尽管拥有这种特权的人通常可以走进咖啡馆并使用里面的设施，但确实有很多人没有这种特权，他们不会被邀请进入咖啡馆并被允许在那里使用厕所。是的，我们依赖于一个私营系统，比如公共厕所，基本上都在私人咖啡馆和
Starbucks and hotel lobbies and things like that. When I travel, I often wear a suit when I travel. And one of the things that I'm going to do is you can walk into any place and use the bathroom as soon as you can. Yeah, I believe that. You've noticed that. I am. Yeah. Yeah. I was sort of like, as I was reading this part, I was imagining a've noticed that. I am. Yeah. I was sort of like, as I was reading this part, I was imagining a string of law in which good public toilets that are well maintained are just part of the city infrastructure and
星巴克、酒店大堂之类的地方。当我旅行时，我通常会穿西装。我要做的一件事是你可以走进任何地方，只要你能，就可以使用洗手间。是的，我相信。你注意到了。我是的。是的。是的。我有点像，当我读到这部分时，我一直在想象一件事情：你注意到了。我是的。是的。是的。我有点像，当我读到这部分时，我一直在想象一类法律，其中维护良好的优质公共厕所只是城市基础设施的一部分，而且
maybe coupled with public transit or something to that effect. It just seems like that would make the world just a tremendously better place, like every city of better place. City planners have forgotten, you know, like the people have basic bodily functions, even when they're outside. I don't know, you can't always run home, and some people don't have homes. One option is to actually pay private establishments to open their toilets up to the public that has worked in some places. Although with the pandemic, with all these establishments closed, you can see the limitations
也许与公共交通或类似的东西相结合。这似乎会让世界变得好得多，就像让每个城市都变得更好一样。城市规划者已经忘记了，你知道的，人们即使在户外也有基本的生理需求。我不知道，你不可能总是跑回家，而且有些人连家都没有。一种选择是实际上花钱请私营机构向公众开放他们的厕所，这在某些地方已经奏效了。尽管随着疫情的爆发，所有这些机构都关门了，你可以看到其局限性
of that, what happens after hours. There's also the possibility of combining toilets, as you said, maybe with public transit, but maybe with a private business, but that the toilet leads. So you have the public toilet, but it's also a cafe or a like a stand for coffee or something like that. You know, they sell things alongside of it and that helps fund the toilets. People want to bring back, some people want to bring back pay toilets, you know, think that people would be willing to pay a little bit for a toilet.
这一点，非营业时间会发生什么。还有一种可能是将厕所结合起来，正如你所说，也许与公共交通结合，也许与私营企业结合，但厕所有所主导。所以你拥有公共厕所，但它也是一家咖啡馆或咖啡摊之类的东西。你知道的，他们在旁边出售东西，这有助于资助厕所。人们希望恢复，有些人希望恢复收费厕所，你知道的，认为人们会愿意为使用厕所支付一点费用。
And I think with apps, you know, that's easier. You don't have to carry around a quarter. You don't have exact change or something for the toilet. But you can just tap your phone and use the toilet. And then you could provide something like toilet stamps for people who couldn't afford it. That sounds promising to me. In the book, you lay out an idealized vision for toilets and you call it Lutopia, which is pretty good. So what does Lutopia look like? Yeah, so I came up for the book with the concept of Lutopia which is a place where our toilets allow us to live in more harmony with each other and with nature and one of the points that's really important to me in this book
而且我认为有了应用程序，你知道的，这更容易了。你不必随身携带25美分的硬币。你不需要准备刚刚好的零钱之类的来上厕所。你只需轻触手机就可以使用厕所。然后你可以为那些付不起钱的人提供类似“厕所券”的东西。这听起来对我很有吸引力。在书中，你为厕所勾勒出了一个理想化的愿景，你称之为“卢托比亚”（Lutopia），这挺不错的。那么“卢托比亚”是什么样子的？是的，所以我在书中提出了“卢托比亚”的概念，这是一个我们的厕所允许我们以更加和谐的方式与彼此以及与自然共同生活的地方，我在本书中真正看重的观点之一
is that there is no one type of toilet in Lutopia, but it's in fact a kaleidoscope of toilets. We have this notion that has come down to us from the past of what the toilet or what the ideal toilet system is, which is what we've been talking about, the flush toilet connected to the sewer system connected to the centralized treatment plan. But what we really need for the future is a range of different kinds of toilet systems that are appropriate for different places with different resources, with different needs. And that is really, I think, how we're going to get to something like Lutopia, where yeah, where toilets are healthier, more sustainable, and more equitable.
在“卢托比亚”中没有单一类型的厕所，相反，它是一个厕所的万花筒。我们有一种从过去继承下来的观念，即什么是厕所或什么是理想的厕所系统，也就是我们一直在谈论的：连接到下水道系统的抽水马桶，连接到集中式处理厂。但我们对未来真正需要的是一系列不同种类的厕所系统，它们适用于具有不同资源、不同需求的各个不同地方。我认为这确实是我们如何能够实现像“卢托比亚”这样地方的方式，是的，在那里厕所更健康、更可持续、更公平。
You may not realize it, but there's a good chance you've been drinking recycled wastewater, and it's been totally fine. More with Chelsea Wald after the break. So, we just published a book last year called The 99% Invisible City and the first chapter of the book is about utility markings and how underground utilities are color coded. Like the color oranges used indicate telecommunications infrastructure and red is for electrical, and you write about lavender. There are lavender utility markings and also lavender pipes. What are those for?
你可能没有意识到，你很有可能一直在饮用回收废水，而且这完全没有问题。中场休息后，将为您带来更多关于切尔西·沃尔德的访谈。所以，我们去年刚出版了一本书叫《99%隐形的城市》，书的第一章是关于地下管线标记以及地下管线是如何按颜色编码的。比如橙色用于表示电信基础设施，红色用于电力，而你写到了薰衣草紫色。有薰衣草紫色的地下管线标记，还有薰衣草紫色的管道。那些是用来做什么的？
The purple is for non-potable water. It's possible to take the water that comes out of a wastewater treatment plant and clean it up to a level where it can be reused very often. You know, it is very clean. It's possibly even cleaner than the water body that it gets charged into at times. More and more, we're going to see water scarcity in our cities and so utilities are reusing this water in some way. Non-potable means you don't drink it, but it's still very useful for things like irrigation, industrial uses, even fleshing toilets. This color purple, it's sort of a really nice lavender color, is the color that arose as the best color in Irvine, California. I think a manager at the wastewater treatment plant who was colorblind found that it stood out. And the really the reason
紫色代表非饮用水。完全有可能将污水处理厂流出的水净化到可以非常频繁地重复使用的程度。你知道的，它非常干净。它甚至可能比它被排放进去的水体还要干净。未来，我们将越来越多地在城市中看到水资源短缺，因此公用事业部门正在以某种方式重复利用这些水。非饮用水意味着你不能饮用它，但它对于灌溉、工业用途甚至冲马桶等事情仍然非常有用。这种紫色，有点像很好看的薰衣草紫，是加利福尼亚州欧文市确定的最佳颜色。我想污水处理厂的一位色盲经理发现它很显眼。其实原因
you want to have different color pipes is because you know, you don't want a plumber to accidentally because you don't want to plumber to accidentally plumb the non-potable water into a drinking fountain say. So that's why you color-coded. People have a hard time with the idea of drinking recycled water. Lots of people would probably feel uncomfortable drinking a glass of water if they were told that it used to be wastewater from someone's toilet. But you write in the book, we're indirectly drinking recycled water all the time. How does that work? So what has been done to now is often instead of feeding it directly into the drinking water system, they will use the water to say recharge groundwater. And then it gets pulled back up into the drinking water system. And so it sort of goes for this inter intermediary step,
你想拥有不同颜色管道的原因是，你知道的，你不会希望水管工不小心，因为你不会希望水管工不小心将非饮用水管道接到饮水机里，比如说。这就是为什么你要进行颜色编码。人们很难接受饮用回收水的想法。如果有人告诉他们这些水曾是某个马桶里的废水，很多人可能会觉得喝一杯这样的水很不舒服。但你在书中写道，我们实际上一直在间接饮用回收水。这是怎么运作的？所以到目前为止所做的事情通常是，他们不用它直接喂给饮用水系统，而是用这些水来补充地下水，比如说。然后它会被抽回饮用水系统中。所以它经历了这个中间步骤，
which is, you know, sort of unnecessary, but useful for sort of cleansing the mind at least. Other people are thinking about sort of clever ways of bringing this concept to people's attention, like using this water to make beer. So beer uses a lot of water. It's not water efficient. And so utilities have been working with these brewers to deliver them this very clean water. Actually, in some cases, it's sort of like very tasteless water because they've cleaned it
你知道的，这在某种程度上是不必要的，但至少对净化心灵很有用。其他人正在考虑将这个概念带给公众的巧妙方法，比如用这种水来酿造啤酒。所以啤酒消耗大量的水。它并不节水。因此，公用事业部门一直与这些酿酒商合作，向他们提供这种非常干净的水。实际上，在某些情况下，它有点像非常淡而无味的水，因为他们已经把它净化过了。
so much of all of minerals and stuff. You know, stuff. They have this sort of clean palette on which to make this beer. I don't know if this is apocryphal or not, but I've heard many times that, for example, the medieval period, people drank beer instead of water because it was safer. So maybe there's also a kind of long history of thinking that the brewing process is a kind of cleansing process for liquid And also, you know, when you drink beer, you pee more. So it's sort of got a circular logic to it as well Because we've lived in a period of time of abundance, I think, and that might be shifting Do you think it's possible to change our thinking about this stuff globally considering the climate change and are you hopeful?
含有大量的矿物质之类的东西。你知道的，就是那些东西。他们拥有这种干净的基底来酿造这种啤酒。我不知道这传言是不是真的，但我多次听说，比如在中世纪，人们喝啤酒而不是水，因为啤酒更安全。所以也许人们长期以来也有一种看法，认为酿造过程是对液体的一种净化过程。而且，你知道，当你喝啤酒时，你会尿得更多。所以它里面也有点循环逻辑，因为我们生活在一个物质丰富的时代，我认为，而这可能会发生改变。考虑到气候变化，你认为在全球范围内改变我们对这种事情的看法有可能吗，你对此抱有希望吗？
Yeah, I think I'm hopeful about it. I mean, it depends on the day how hopeful I am about the global situation that we find ourselves in. In general, it's not such a hard topic for me to cover as an environmental journalist because plastic pollution kind of depresses me because every time I use a piece of plastic I feel guilty and bad about it. But I don't really have to feel bad about pooping. I mean, it's just something every animal does. And so it's all opportunity. There's room for a lot of different solutions. It is a problem that we have to confront as a species. It's also hyper-local. So it's like the scales go from extremely
是的，我觉得我对此抱有希望。我的意思是，我对我们所处的全球局势抱有多大希望，取决于具体是哪一天。总的来说，作为一个环境记者，这对我来说不是一个很难报道的话题，因为塑料污染有点让我沮丧，因为每次我使用一块塑料我都感到内疚和糟糕。但我真的不需要为排便感到糟糕。我的意思是，这只是每个动物都会做的事情。所以这一切都是机会。这里有很多不同的解决方案有待实现。这是我们作为一个物种必须直面的问题。它也具有极强的地域性。所以它的规模跨度从极其
local, like your own private toilet and what you can do there to the global and every scale in between. I found in my reporting, people at all those scales doing all that kind of work, maybe not everyone's paying attention to that, but it is going on. And I think the more that people tie what they're doing into larger global issues that are really concerning all of us, the more that those innovations can take hold. Thank you so much for the book
本地化，比如你自己的私人厕所和你在那里能做的事情，一直到全球范围以及介于两者之间的每一个尺度。在我的报道中，我发现人们在所有这些尺度上都在做所有这些工作，也许不是每个人都在关注这一点，但我认为它正在发生。并且我认为，人们越是将他们所做的事情与真正关切我们所有人的更大全球性问题联系起来，那些创新就越能扎根。非常感谢你写这本书
and for talking with me, Chelsea. Oh, thanks so much for having me. This was really fun. Chelsea Wald is the author of the book, Pipe Dreams, the urgent global quest to transform the toilet, get it, wherever fine books are sold. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Baroube, music by our director of Sound John Rial, sound mixed by Andy Christen's daughter. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson,
并和我交谈，切尔西。哦，非常感谢邀请我来。这真的很有趣。切尔西·瓦尔德是《管道之梦：改造厕所的紧迫全球探索》一书的作者，懂了吧，各大优质书店均有销售。《99%无形》本周由克里斯·巴鲁布制作，音乐由我们的音响总监约翰·里亚尔创作，混音由安迪·克里斯滕斯多特完成。我们的资深制作人是德兰尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括维维安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克ристофер·约翰逊、
Lasha Madonna, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a part of this stature and serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi org, or on Instagram and read it too.
拉沙·麦当娜、凯蒂·明格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我罗曼·马斯。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于美丽的奥克兰上城向北六个街区，加利福尼亚州。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，或者在节目账号 99pi org 上，或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你也可以在上面找到我们。
You can find other shows I love from Stitcher on our website at 99pi.org, including Freakonomics, uncovering the hidden stories of the world through the lens of economics. Find a link to it in every past episode of 99PI at 99pi.org. Hey, Sue, don't have an audio logo. I haven't set up my email yet. I think that might be the problem. So, um, okay. Duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, your head, Stitcher. Stitcher in your head, da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上找到我喜欢的来自 Stitcher 的其他节目，包括《魔鬼经济学》，它通过经济学的镜头揭示世界隐藏的故事。在 99pi.org 的每一期往期节目中都可以找到它的链接。嘿，苏，没有音频标志。我还没设置好我的电子邮件。我想那可能是问题所在。所以，嗯，好吧。呃，哒哒哒哒，你的头，Stitcher。你脑子里的 Stitcher，哒哒哒哒……本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。